[Music]
my name is Zoltan urato I'm a product
manager of Google Cloud IOT core let me
also introduce Preston Holmes head of
IOT solutions for Google also he's gonna
be on stage with us shortly so today we
are going to talk about a specific type
of IOT applications applications those
involve of course IOT devices mobile
mobile or web applications and very
importantly also users and you are going
to see that users will be an important
component in this presentation and as
part of this presentation we will review
sort of the theoretical background the
business context and then we will show
you a tool box using cloud IT core and
some of the firebase product how you
could implement these use cases and we
will finish with the demo
so both Preston and I have been working
in around IOT projects or on IOT
projects for almost five years now and
we have seen two main patterns emerging
when it comes to IOT use cases the first
one is I like to call them data
ingestion intensive or data ingestion
heavy use cases in these use cases there
are many devices sending a lot of data
upstream so typically the bandwidth
requirement upstream is much higher than
downstream and usually these are
applications for monitoring or analytics
and I mentioned that users will be an
important part of our talk and and in
these use cases usually there are less
personas involved on the other hand the
other type of application we we usually
see when working with
steamers we like to call it complex
application logic use cases so in these
use cases or applications the data model
is usually more complex there is a
similar need in terms of bandwidth
requirement upstream and downstream and
that's because it these applications are
not only about receiving data from
devices but also controlling them
so most of the time this complex
business logic is used to determine some
sort of change that is required to be
performed on the devices and then send
back these commands or configurations to
the devices and what makes
implementation of these use cases
challenging is a is the the multiple
personas sort of in the mix or having to
interact with these deployments so when
it comes to these complex application
logic use cases typically these are the
building blocks that we see as required
for implementation so mobile and web
applications to control the devices and
see their actual state the devices of
course device management capabilities
meaning like credential management
grouping updating or updating the
firmware of the devices cloud services
data management tools in the cloud or
storage solutions or computing solutions
user management so most commonly an
identity provider to store your users
and then handle your users we already
touched upon command and control so the
capability to to to interact with the
devices to be able to control them and
last but not least sensor data
aggregation and visualization so you
want to see your or in these use cases
users one
see sensor data or aggregated data of of
device of one device or multiple devices
and there is a horizontal layer here so
all these building blocks are used by
various users and personas and and these
users have may have very different
access control needs or limitations and
this is going to be a focus in our talk
how to implement authorization for these
users because we have seen that many
times this is very challenging so
depending on how the business is run the
same building blocks are used and there
are free main categories here we are
going to see examples for each so b2b
business to business b2b to be there is
another be added here and B - B - C and
the first B is is always the IOT or or
cloud service provider so in our case
its Google cloud and then the second B
is our customer and in many times our
customers operate a service some sort of
SAS service and IOT solution using our
infrastructure and sell these services
either to businesses or our consumers so
to give you an example of all of these
probably the b2b scenario is the is the
simplest in terms of implementation and
probably the best example would be a
connected factory or connected
manufacturing line so so a factory with
connected PLC's when it comes to
implementing these use cases based on
these business models usually it's
enough to use the resources provided by
by the de cloud
is provider so inkay in this case Google
cloud so these are existing resources or
building blocks and and implementing
these use cases can rely only on these
component and very importantly there are
no end users in b2b use cases this is a
little bit more complicated to be to be
to be scenario may be the best way to
describe the this category of use cases
is through an example so imagine a
connected truck fleet management system
a company that provides this truck fleet
management services as a SAS service and
they also let's say they also sell
hardware that their customers can
install in their trucks or it can be
other vehicle as well and there are
end-users in this in this scenario so if
you think about the customers of the SAS
provider so the connected truck fleet
management system provider those users
are end-users so for instance a driver
or operator of of of a given fleet and
we have to realize that in these use
cases there is a really wide spectrum of
roles and permissions so just to reflect
on my my previous example a driver has
really different access rights compared
to the manager of a whole fleet to B to
B to C scenario is a little bit simpler
but similar to the previous one probably
this is the most familiar to all of you
a good example would be a smart lighting
solution really the only difference here
is that the
the end users are consumers and and in
these use cases there are multiple
personas and and rules and permission
requirements but typically less than in
case of b2b to be I wanted to show you a
real world example and it's very
relevant here in San Francisco so you
might have seen these scooters out on
the street these are connected scooters
so they are connected to the Internet
and there is a corresponding app or
there is an app you need to use if you
wanna if you want to ride the scooters
and there is a very complex business
logic behind the disservice so if you
think about it the user of the
application and the scooter needs to
gain access rights to the to the scooter
just for the period of that person is
riding the scooter so there this is a
pretty complex business logic here and
and then they are actually using Google
cloud services just to give you a
summary of these various business models
or or sort of overview them so in all
cases the manufacturer is is some kind
of device maker or or an OEM that's
that's common in in all three scenarios
when it comes to the owner of of the
devices so who owns the device in case
of b2b this is trivial it's it's the
it's the customer of the cloud service
provider so it's a corporate owner or an
operator and there is no end user in
case of b2b in the other two categories
there are end users in case of b2b to be
the the interesting thing is that the
owner is also a corporate owner and/or
operator but the end user is different
so they not necessarily own the hardware
so just to
reflect back on the truck fleet
management system these dis hardware or
these tracking devices might be
installed on trucks but but let's say
the driver of the truck doesn't
necessarily own the device in case of B
to B to C this is a little bit simpler
because in these use cases usually the
owner and the end-user
are the same person so think about the
connected light example alright so when
it comes to the implementation and we
will go into the actual details very
soon
but just to review that there are two
main layers of the sort of back-end
implementation of these use cases
application and infrastructure just like
in other other systems this is true in
IOT as well so what's typical for
infrastructure is that usually there are
cloud services and these are
pre-existing building blocks so for
instance like compute engine instances
or devices but there are many of them in
Google cloud what's common is that there
is a service called cloud iam and cloud
iam controls that what sort of
permissions a given user has on what
resources and in this layer the
resources are obviously defined by the
cloud service provider so in our case
it's defined by Google and typically for
in case of b2b use cases the
implementation is heavier on this layer
in this layer so there is less need for
for an application layer because you can
usually use these pre-existing building
blocks the application layer this is
where the business logic most of the
business logic is implemented this is
where
the command and control decisions are
made and and this is the layer
responsible for for transmitting these
decisions to the infrastructure layer we
can look at this layer as the digital
version of of the business model of a
given use case and this layer is usually
figure in case of the B to B to B and B
to B to C use cases now an interesting
question is that of course these two
layers live together so they are
implemented together and and and both
exist and there is always some sort of
overlap between the two and the question
is how do we crossover between the two
layers how do we bridge between a device
that only exists as an infrastructure
piece and it's authorization is
controlled by I am so how do we provide
access to this device for a user that
for instance only exists in a third
party identity provider which is which
can be even external to Google and the
good news is that Google has solutions
to solve these problems and we have
tools to implement these authorization
control mechanisms and so I would like
to invite Preston on stage to tell more
how to do that thank you so 10 so we
talked about the general cases of the
infrastructure layer and the application
layer so if we look first at some of the
infrastructure ways that we can apply I
am in IOT cloud IOT core which is our
primary service for authorizing and
identifying and securely connecting
devices that exist out in the in sort of
the field to cloud this service has a
set of i.m permissions and roles that
let
you define who can do what with the
logical device resources that are stored
in IOT core and like many cloud I am
permissions these can be applied at
different scopes of influence so this is
an example of where these permissions
can be applied to the entire project but
inside cloud IOT core we also provide
the ability to apply these permissions
or roles to specific device registries
or collections within a project so this
is something where you're applying glad
I am to control who can access or who
can perform certain actions on cloud
resources defined by Google in a managed
service like cloud IOT core the other
thing you can use I am for is is
controlling access to who can publish to
certain cloud pub/sub topic so cloud IOT
core and cloud pub/sub are very tightly
integrated and by limiting who can
publish to certain topics you can
constrain pub/sub that there only only
messages being published by devices
through IOT core arrive on a pub
subtopic and this is important because
that way you can use certain attributes
published by IOT core on messages such
as a device ID and know that those
attributes were only coming through
devices and not through some other cloud
publisher online that has access to that
pub subtopic so it's one of the
constraints you can put on other systems
that IOT core interacts with now the the
title of this talk was IOT and firebase
and firebase is actually a very large
suite of products and services and we're
certainly not going to cover them all
today there is also the fact that a
number of these services now sort of
have dual representations in both sort
of the firebase experience and the cloud
GCP experience so the ones were going to
be touching on our authentication
hosting firestore and cloud functions so
authentication is the kind of customer
identity management I'll get into that
in sec hosting a static hosting fire
store is a document database
and then cloud functions again this is
the same back-end infrastructure shared
between Google cloud platform and
firebase as far as executing lightweight
functions so the first is around
identity management so when Zoltan was
talking about the main components this
is how you manage your own users so when
you do have end-users involved you need
a way of managing who they are this
handles user authentication recognizing
that these users exist in your system so
when a developer logs into Google cloud
platform our Google identity system is
what we expect infrastructure users to
be able to log into now you can you can
integrate that with ad etc but that's
identity management for infrastructure
this is identity management that we
offer as a service for you to
incorporate into your own applications
and once you have authentication then to
address authorization this is where
firebase rules that apply to firestore
come in and this is a service that
allows applications to communicate
directly to the database without needing
to go through any sort of API
middle-tier and if you're going to have
applications talking directly to a
database you need to apply authorization
logic and the way we do that is we allow
we have a service that basically lets
you describe that authorization syntax
in your application and have the
database actually apply that for you so
we'll get a little bit more into some of
the syntax for these rules a little
later but let's talk about the kind of
architecture we're going to show and
demonstrate here and that is we've got
some devices on the Left these are kind
of hypothetical sort of gas sensors in
this case we're going to use and then
users end users interacting with an
application on the right so the first
thing we do is we're going to use cloud
IOT core to securely connect the devices
to the cloud and then on the application
side we're going to host the static
content related to the application and
and deliver that to
users in in in web browsers or mobile
applications from firebase hosting and
then the live data that the application
is going to be interacting with is going
to come from fire store but because fire
store is directly connected to the
application we're going to make sure
that fire store rules are applied to the
way the application is getting data in
and out of fire store now to connect
these two for device sensor data we're
going to use the cloud ID course
integration with pub/sub and then cloud
functions that take readings from
sensors and write them into fire store
we also could have chosen other cloud
platform data based products to do this
for example we could write this Center
series data and cloud BigTable very
scalable way of doing series data to be
honest and in this case it would have
also meant we would have had to replace
the fire store rules with our own
authorization implementations so we're
going to go with the simple path here
and just use fire store because it gives
us that rules sort of value we're also
going to send information from the
device in the fire store about the
current settings and state of the device
so this isn't necessarily the sensor
data but this might be other current
settings and values that are on the
device changing less often and then
finally when a user changes a setting in
a device we need to get that back out to
the device so again we use a cloud fire
store trigger to run a cloud function
when data changes in fire store and that
cloud function then can send the updated
configuration through IOT core to the
device so when you put it all together
it looks a little something like this so
what we're really trying to leverage
here is using as many server lists and
managed services we've got Direction
data flowing in both directions and then
we've got static content and data being
served to an end-user application so the
the scenario for this demo is going to
be sort of a hypothetical technician who
needs to check out a piece of equipment
and here is my gas sensor that we're
going to use and what they're going to
end up doing is connect to it through a
mobile app so this is I'm going to test
the demo gods because I've got in IOT
device a tablet and a demo laptop all
concurrently interacting with the our
Wi-Fi saturated world so I'm gonna plug
into this so if we can have the demo
system up got it all right so let's
start with the we can go ahead and I'm
going to restart the the casting here so
if we can have the look that has the and
reconnect the a/v guys loved our
requirements list for this one all right
so here's the tablet I'm gonna launch
this app so the first thing is let me go
ahead and back out I'm going to log out
so this app really doesn't do anything
until you log in so when I log in with
Google that's actually maybe I'll just
keep it that way honestly when I log in
with Google
I've already authorized this app so
directly is going to go to a list of
devices that are associated with me this
is a new device I've just kind of
checked this out of a rack say a shared
rack at the technician and what's
displayed on here is a code that says
let me as an employee claim this device
so that I have sort of exclusive control
over it so if I add this claim ID and
it's my favorite one so I'm just going
to name it fav most of you won't be able
to see this change but I'll hit claim
and as long as the network is still good
and connected here this now says claimed
so
the device is now recognized that it's
claimed so I'm going to go into the
detail view here so what you see on that
real-time live graph is is light data
light sensor data coming from this
device and that's coming to that
telemetry path that I showed in the
architecture you're also can see that
there are set of configuration settings
and that is a tilt threshold and so what
that means is I have angle set that if I
tilt this device past a certain range I
get a beep now as a user if I want to
change the tolerance of those tilt
settings I can go ahead and in this app
I'm going to narrow those down let me
just actually narrow one side here and
when I hit update you see the little
spinner up in the dialog that's actually
letting me know that it's taken a moment
for the settings to get to the device
and then the device it's doing that
again huh well what you can see here is
I've narrowed the tilt setting and now
it's a lot more sensitive right let me
we'll go one more time we have enough
time that I can you bear with me will
this is a relatively older tablet that I
pulled out for this particular thing so
I think between us and the stage so
before it glitches again I'll do this
one more time I'll change the setting
and I'll update it and in fact I'll do
it again one more time I'll narrow this
other direction of tilt hopefully I
didn't put it into a state of here we'll
see here that now if I tilt this
essentially what I'm tilting but what I
want to do is show you back on the
laptop a little bit about what's going
on here so that that progress spinner is
actually giving the user of the tablet
an indication that the settings have not
yet actually been verified as received
by the device so I change a setting in
the UI I update the setting that changes
data in cloud firestore
that change of data in cloud firestore
triggers a cloud function to run and
send the new settings down to the device
through IOT core when the device
receives the settings that applies them
to the tilt sensor it that sends another
state update message back through that
other top pathway which confirms the
state as updated in firestore and only
when do those two data values reconcile
does the spinner go away so when you saw
me update a setting in the tablet and
the you saw a spinner for a moment
that's actually a sort of a full
round-trip to the device and back
confirming those settings I'm gonna show
you a little bit more about how these
firebase rules apply because these rules
are what are preventing one user from
seeing data from a device or changing
setting of settings of a device while
another user has that device claimed and
the syntax of these rules is based
around matching patterns of a document
in firestore so first of all the the
outcome of a rule is to allow or not
allow a given device so essentially it's
denied by default and unless a matching
rule is found don't allow the user to
actually read or write data from the
database so you can see the the
operations can be read or write there's
actually also update and delete and the
the main one I want to point out is the
kind of middle section here so well go
from the top which is that the first
rule is around letting a user basically
update their own users profile right and
that makes sense unless the user the
requests coming from the user matches
the profile users ID you can't update
somebody else's profile the second one
is related to the device record itself
so in this case we want to allow
a person to create a new record if
they're going to be the first to claim a
device that can have that entered they
also can read and write the settings for
a given device because that's where the
updating of settings is being written to
and then the telemetry path this is
where we're storing incoming sensors so
that real time line graph was going to a
telemetry collection just to back up and
give a little bit more context for those
who don't know as much on on the
firestore front and the document
database documents are organized into
collections so here we're talking about
three different collections users
devices and telemetry and the way fire
straw rules are applied is you can apply
them only to documents and collections
that match certain patterns in the case
of the middle one here what we're doing
is we're taking the device ID which is
also in this case the document ID and
using that as a variable in the rule and
just to show you the way this works from
the at the actual database layer I have
another user logged in to the same
system and since the URL path was used
for getting the data from that device if
I try to put in that device URL you'll
see that not only is it being blocked at
the web frontend logic but if you look
at the developer console the the
permission error is actually coming from
the database right so if I didn't show
you this developer console it'd be very
easy to sort of say oh well this is
authorization logic happening in the
application in the front-end that is
subject to bugs and errors in the way
authorization is applied so here by
seeing the developer console I can show
you that this is actually being enforced
at the firebase client library and
back-end in a
raishin point if i go ahead and we don't
need to put the tablet up but i will go
ahead and and release this device from
this user and if i go back i can now
claim this
and now I can see it and now I can
actually get to that URL for the detail
view so that's how we're able to use
sort of the real-time nature of firebase
firestore to basically apply these rules
based on the data that's in the database
I think that's the other key takeaway
for firestore rules is that they are
applied per request per document in a
way that lets your own rules and your
own data models in the database be that
custom application layer of
authorization so while I am has a focus
on the resources or the models that are
defined by Google if you're defining the
the sort of application objects in
firestore you can apply firestore rules
in a custom way to those to those
objects in that data
[Music]